[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAFAEL: Welcome, everyone
to this another episode
of Talks at Google.
We're very honored to have two
fantastic speakers here today.
I want to start with
Marianne, Marianne Kent-Stoll.
She is the president and founder
of the Karimu International
Help Foundation.
She's also the assistant
head of the Idyllwind Arts
Academy in the States.
She has been an educator
for more than 30 years.
And she's a mother of four.
So welcome here at
the Google office.
And then I have the pleasure
to actually announce
my old boss who used to be
VP at Google and at IBM.
And he has a long fantastic
career in the IT space,
in the tech space.
He comes back today in
a different function.
So he has since
left Google and has
made a career as an advisor,
as a member of, I think,
six boards.
But he also has, and he always
had that even back at Google,
he was very involved with NGOs.
This is one of them.
So we're going to
be very excited.
We're excited about the
talk and the story here.
He's an avid world traveler.
I know this firsthand.
He's visited more than
50% of all countries.
And he is also a
family-oriented person.
He's a role model
for many Googlers
here, so welcome back at Google.
Please, both, take
it away from here.
NELSON MATTOS: All right.
MARIANNE KENT-STOLL: Thank you,
everyone, for inviting me here.
It's really my honor to be here.
As Rafael said, I am
the founder of Karimu.
And I work at an
arts boarding school.
And my passion is for
Karimu Foundation,
which my husband and
I founded in 2007.
And I'm thrilled that Nelson
is now part of the Karimu team
and invited me here today.
Thank you very much.
NELSON MATTOS:
Thank you, Marianne.
I'm going to skip the
little bit of my background.
You already heard
enough from Rafael.
Let me get right into the topic
of the presentation, which
is to give you a sense of what
is wrong with existing NGOs.
And what is an
approach that I believe
is successful to do
social development.
As some of you know, about one
third of the world's population
continues to live in poverty,
which is about people
that earn less than $2 a day.
From this 2.4 billion
people, 70% of them
live in rural areas,
with a large majority
in sub-Saharan Africa
and South Asia.
Obviously, these folks
live in these situations.
Some of you have
seen these pictures
when I was here two years ago.
All of these pictures,
including all the pictures
that you're going to see
in this presentation,
are pictures that either
I took in my world travels
or that Marianne and her
volunteers took from the work
in Tanzania.
So you have lack of sanitation.
You can see what
this kid is doing.
The other one down the
river is drinking the water.
This is a typical house in the
interior of sub-Saharan Africa,
or here's another one.
Or this is a typical
village in some places.
You also have issues
with transportation.
This is a fancy
transportation in many parts
of sub-Saharan Africa with
people even on the top
or something like this.
This is a feeding
station in Somalia.
This girl is four
and 1/2 years old.
And this is the whole hospital
where there is no nurses.
The mothers or grandmothers
that take the kids there
to get fed so they
don't starve, basically
have to take care of them.
So this is a situation that
actually a lot of people
live even as of today.
When you look at what
are all the big issues,
the big challenges
that the poor faces,
you could actually
categorize the challenges
in three classes,
in three categories.
And in order for you to really
take people out of poverty,
you have to address
these three issues.
The first one, given
that the majority of them
are living from
agriculture, they
live in the interior
of these countries,
it's super important to
increase their productivity
and increase their income.
Most of them have very
small pieces of land.
They don't have money to buy
fertilizers and pesticides,
et cetera, so their
production is very small.
And consequently, their
profit is also very small.
On top of that, they are
dependent on a middle man that
comes to the village
to buy their goods
and go sell in a larger market.
And that middle man
is, in most cases,
basically getting the
biggest profits because they
know how to handle.
The second major
category is health.
You have the issue of
some of these folks
not having access to
good health services
or not having the money to
pay for health services.
Or if they have
an emergency, they
may not even have the means
to pay for somebody to drive
or take them into a hospital.
And the third issue
is related to access
to financial services.
Right?
In our society,
if you need money,
you actually will take a loan.
We all have credit history.
And it's easy for
us to get to money.
However, for all of these guys
that live in the countryside
there is no banking
system available for them.
They don't have credit history.
And so if an emergency
happens, and they
don't have means to borrow
money or get from somebody else,
they basically need to sell the
little things that they have.
They may need to sell the cow
that feeds and provides milk
to the kids in the family.
And now, they basically
go deeper and deeper
into this hole.
And as you can see, all of
these issues are interconnected.
Right?
If I don't have access
to financial systems,
I cannot take a loan at the
beginning of my agriculture
phase and buy the necessary
fertilizer and pesticides
to increase my productivity.
Similarly, if I don't
have this, and now I
have a family emergency,
I have to sell
things that are super important
for me to be able to survive.
I have seen people
selling the seeds in order
to pay for the
visit to a doctor.
Well, and now you
don't have seeds,
how do you produce your income?
I get asked this
question quite often.
And that's why I decided to
put explicitly on the slides.
Education is not a challenge.
The lack of education is
really or education is really
a means to address
some of these issues.
In particularly, how to
improve your own income
and how to become healthier.
So while a lot of NGOs, and
including the work that Karimu
does, does focus on education,
it's really not the challenge
itself.
The three biggest challenges
you really need to focus on
is income, health, and
access to financial systems.
So as some of you know that
know a little bit of my history,
I have been involved in
NGOs for over 10 years
in different ways.
I'm on the board
of some of them.
I advise other NGOs.
And I work as a
volunteer as well.
And while I think it's wonderful
the work that they do, and it's
super gratifying to see the
positive impact of a project,
sometimes it's
really aggravating
when you see failures
happening on the ground.
And these failures are
related to a few problems that
are highly connected with the
way NGOs have been operating
until very recently.
The first major problem, and
that requires a little bit
of explaining, has
to do with the fact
that there is a vacuum
between NGOs that
do the execution on the
ground and the big donors.
So in the past, you
usually would have
kind of two types of NGOs--
those that are small
doing execution
on a specific country.
They only focus on
a specific region.
Or they focus on
a specific topic.
Somebody builds schools.
Somebody build bridges.
Somebody does hospital.
Somebody helps with vaccination.
And then you had middleman
NGOs, so large NGOs
that don't do the
execution, but they
build comprehensive
projects that
together brings
many NGOs together
to address all
those three issues.
And somebody will
focus on health.
Somebody will help income.
Somebody will do
financial services.
The NGOs define a comprehensive
project for all of them.
And then work, and as
occurred in these projects
across the globe with
different NGOs that
are physically represented
in the different countries.
Unfortunately, these
middlemen NGOs,
and Karumi Foundation is
are a good example of those,
are dying.
And the main reason
is because technology
has enabled the donors
to communicate directly
with the small
NGOs on the ground.
And obviously, they
also want to make sure
that every penny
that they donate
goes directly to the
impact of the projects.
And for them, these
middlemen NGOs
are almost like a tax
on the project itself.
That has created a
vacuum because even when
you do manage to
create a solution,
beautiful on some country,
there is nobody now
to generalize that solution
and replicate across the globe.
And what we are starting
to see is lots of one-offs.
So either you see a
solution that work here,
and there is nobody else
to replicate and bring it
to a different country, or
you have the issue of yes,
I solved the education
problem in some place
or the financial systems
problem someplace,
but there is nobody else
active in this region
to deal with health or to
deal with the income issue.
And so consequences
of this problem
is you are starting to see lots
and lots of one-off solutions
that are obviously
successful, but they are not
scalable or sustainable
to really address
the problem worldwide.
Or you have as point solutions
they are really not addressing
all the three challenges
that I described before.
The second problem is that
the smaller NGOs do not
have the time to spend
interacting with the community
and ensuring that they
understand the peculiarities
of their culture.
And also obtaining their
buy-in to different projects.
The donors give them money.
They want the results
as soon as possible.
They don't give any money
that is not directly related
to the project.
And consequently,
these guys come in.
They want to execute.
Then they want to move out.
And obviously, if you don't
interact with the community,
if you don't involve them, if
you don't get their buy-in,
the consequence
is, yeah, you may
get fantastic short-term
results, but the NGO leaves,
and then everything falls apart.
So midterm to long-term,
the value is gone.
The positive impact disappears.
Or if the long-term
impact remains,
usually it happens
because now there
is a dependence on the presence
of that NGO on the ground.
So as long as the NGO
is there supporting,
leading, driving the
project, then you
continue to see the impact.
But the moment they
leave, it will fall apart.
So you create a dependency.
And this is really bad because
if you create dependency,
you really don't have
a sustainable solution.
Similar to the previous
one, the smaller NGOs
don't have time to really
work with the communities
so that they have
skin in the game,
so that they own the project.
So they come in, usually they
bring people from the outside,
execute the project,
and they move out.
And so the community
is not involved,
doesn't understand the project,
does not know how to drive it,
how to continue to execute.
And then you have
similar issues--
lack of sustainability.
Once the project is
completed, the NGO's
disconnected because
you really did not
get the community to feel
that this is their project.
It is their responsibility
to maintain.
You don't sustain it.
Or similar to the
previous point,
you do have positive
impact long-term,
but now it's because
of the NGO is there
and you create a dependency.
And similar to the
previous one, they also
don't have the
time and the money
to obtain trust
from the community.
And this is
particularly important
when you want to change
people's behavior.
Right?
If somebody for their whole life
has been working or reacting
in a certain way, and
you want to change
the way these people
operate or behave,
in order for you to
help them change,
they really need to trust you.
They really need to
believe you know better.
They really need
to know you have
good intentions, et
cetera, et cetera.
And to build trust and strong
relationships with people
take time.
And that investment is
not funded by the donors
because it's not dollar that
goes directly into a project.
Consequently, you see that
donors come in, but not,
as you see in this
picture, spending
enough time with the
community to gain their trust.
And you have exactly
the same points.
Right?
You may get positive results,
short-term but not long-term.
Or if you do see long-term
positive results,
it's because you have created
a dependency on the NGO.
So summarizing, the
problems are the vacuum
that exist in terms
of replicating
the solutions because the
middle managers have disappear.
And the fact that the smaller
NGOs are under the gun
to show results, and
they don't have the time
to understand the
peculiarities and the culture
of the community,
gain their buy-in,
make sure that they feel
ownership of the projects
and really trust you.
And the consequences,
as I have mentioned,
you end up with solutions
that don't address all three
key challenges.
So you may fix health
issues, but you
didn't address the other ones.
So people remain poor.
Or you do fix the income
issue, but they still
don't have enough good health.
Obviously, lack of scalable
and sustainable solutions.
The dependency on the NGOs
to maintain long-term results
or the lack of long-term results
because the NGOs disappear.
There is no ownership
from the community.
So I have been, even though
I love the work of NGOs,
I have been quite frustrated for
a long time with exactly that.
And so my wife and
I were seriously
considering creating our
own NGO so that we actually
don't make those mistakes.
We probably would
make other mistakes,
like nobody's perfect, but at
least we would not do those.
And talking to different
people that ran NGOs,
and particularly talking
to an organization called
Inspire World that does organize
volunteer trips to Africa
and Asia, they
introduced me to Karimu.
And by talking to
Marianne, she convinced me
to go last year to Africa as
part of the volunteer team.
And when I went
there, my wife and I,
and we saw the
way they operated,
I was amazed to see that
none of these problems
existed with the
way Karimu operated.
And that's how the
partnership started.
But before I get
into that, let me
let Marianne give you a little
bit of the history of Karimu.
MARIANNE KENT-STOLL: Thank you.
And thank you, Nelson.
I did not anticipate that
Nelson would be so taken
by the village that he would
want to join us and continue
to go to the village.
Because I knew that he had been
involved with so many NGOs,
I thought, why would he
want to be involved with us?
We are relatively small.
My husband and I
have full-time jobs.
And we only go to this village
two weeks out of every year.
But we have been going
there for 10 years.
And you will be hearing
throughout my talk
kind of a mantra over and
over that without trust,
without relationship,
and without learning
from the people,
nothing can happen.
You know, how many of
you-- you've probably
heard this saying before, if
you give a man a fish for a day,
he'll eat for a day.
If you teach a man how to
fish, then he can eat for life.
Well, I've kind of
added on to this,
which is I truly
believe after spending
10 years with the people
of Dareda, many of them
already know how to fish.
They don't need to
learn how to fish.
They just need the resources.
And the model that
we ended up doing
was not something specifically
that we masterminded.
We just were dropped in
this village on vacation
and realized that we
had to do something.
So I'm going to
backtrack a little bit
and tell you the story
of what happened.
We were tourists in
Tanzania in 2007.
And we did a cultural stay
in the village of Dareda.
We lived with 11 children
in a kind of a brick hut
kind of structure with no
electricity and no running
water.
And before we arrived
on this cultural stay,
I kept getting emails from our
cultural tour operator, who
is now our director and guy on
the ground in Tanzania, saying,
do you want to participate
in a school project?
And we were saying,
yeah, that sounds great.
So we were envisioning
that there would
be an NGO in this village.
And that Don and I would happily
come and shovel some dirt
and give a couple of hundred
dollars and be on our way.
But when we arrived
at the school
and saw the deplorable
condition of the classrooms,
there was no windows, no doors,
200 students at this school,
only two usable classrooms.
So that means all different
age levels in a classroom.
Right?
There were two other classrooms
that had walls but no roof
because the government
says to the villagers
if you build the walls,
we will provide the roof.
Well, they'd been waiting
for years for the roof.
And so the walls were
already starting to crumble.
The worst of it is--
the worst of it was the toilet.
There was a shallow
hole in the ground,
literally, not even a cement pit
latrine or anything like that.
It looked like somebody
had taken a shovel
and dug a big hole
in it and put sticks
in some burlap sacks around it.
And this hole in the ground was
supposed to serve 200 people.
The government was going
to close the school
because, even by rural African
standards, it was not sanitary.
So I looked across the yard, and
I saw this half built latrine.
There were, it looked
like the possibility
of maybe having six latrines.
And I said, well,
what's going on there?
And they said,
well, the villagers
started making it years ago,
but they ran out of money.
And I said, well, how
much money do you need?
He said $500.
And my husband and I
looked at each other.
And we thought, well,
this is a no-brainer.
We can give them $500
to fix the latrine.
And then the school
will stay open.
So we only had
$200 in our pocket
because we were very naive.
We thought we could
cash travelers checks
in rural Tanzania.
And it turned out that
we were just like, OK,
we only have is $200 here.
But will this do?
And we'll wire you
money when we get home.
And they were just
singing and dancing.
You'd think, this was
the greatest thing
that ever happened.
The toilet, the
toilet was mentioned--
I couldn't understand
Swahili, but the toilet
was mentioned in every
song that they made up.
And so we were
getting ready to leave
and my husband tends to be
very direct because he doesn't
like to get people's hopes up.
And he said to the head
teacher, Paul Yoronimo, Paul,
we have enjoyed our stay,
but we are teachers.
And we have to go back to work.
And we're probably not going
to come to this village
again, because this was
a trip of a lifetime
that we'd been saving for.
But we will do
fundraisers at school.
And we'll send the
money back to you.
Well, Paul looked to my husband
with these big brown liquid
eyes, grabbed his arm, and said
Mr. Don, we need your money,
but you are part
of our family now.
And you must come back.
And so, of course, he
tugged at our heartstrings.
And we went home and started
creating a nonprofit called
Karimu.
When I look back at
that moment with Paul,
I think that was our guiding
light from the very beginning
because Paul along
with the other teachers
could have easily taken
advantage of Don and me.
We were naive.
We had not done any
development work.
He could have said
sure, send the money.
And this happens
so often in Africa
where money gets absconded with.
And then the projects
don't get done.
We could have been
easily taken in.
But what he wanted was an
ongoing relationship with us.
He didn't want just the money.
And just this past
week or so ago when
we were in the
village, I was talking
to our longtime friend
Mr. [? Kayia, ?]
who's also the assistant
project manager.
And I asked him about
this first visit.
And I said, why were you so
insistent that we return?
And he's very adamant
and very strong.
And he said if you
are not friends
and you just bring money,
if there is no relationship,
you throw money in the pit.
We don't want that.
And so we went back, as I said,
and we started the nonprofit.
And also being in
education we were
able to recruit 28 volunteers.
So in the summer of 2008, we
arrived at this Ufani School
and started building the
first four classrooms.
And it was there that we learned
the importance of working side
by side, of working
with the villagers,
getting our hands dirty,
partnering on the construction.
And not only that,
I was overwhelmed
with the amount of people that
wanted to meet with Don and me.
We met with the village council.
We met with doctors,
nurses, school leaders.
We were invited to sit
in huts and have meals,
walk the long red dirt roads.
And wherever you walk, I
mean, Nelson knows this,
wherever you walk,
there's a meeting going on
because you have
to go to one school
to the next there's five people
that say can I talk to you,
can I talk to you.
But it was through this putting
time into the relationship
and learning from them
what their life was
like, Don and I have been
coming there for 10 years.
I could go there
for 20 years and not
really understand the struggles
that these people have
in their daily lives.
So who am I or anybody else
to come in here and say here's
a solution to your problem
when you don't even
live there and have to deal with
the struggles that they have.
So we continued doing this
volunteer work every summer.
And over the period
of five years, ta-da!
This is Ufani School.
Now, after many years,
there are 10 classrooms,
two teachers' offices, three
teachers' houses, 12 pit
latrines.
And then through going
slow on this project,
and not feeling like we have
to, as they say in Swahili,
[SWAHILI],, hurry, hurry,
hurry, not doing that,
we developed a really
strong relationship
with the teachers and
a friendship with them.
And then we started supporting
professional development.
Then we started buying books.
Then we started hearing
about their daily challenges.
We started hearing that
some of the teachers
couldn't get to school because
there was a little footbridge
was washed out.
So they needed a bridge.
So we said, OK, well, I guess
we better find a way to do that.
So we partnered
with an NGO in Kenya
called Bridging the Gap
Africa and built a suspension
walking bridge.
And what people might think
is wow, this is a small NGO
and it sounds like Marianne
and Don are all over the map.
You know?
Why don't they just
focus on one thing?
But again, if we go back
to we asked the villagers
to come up with a list of needs.
We look at their priorities.
And then we also think about the
children going to that school.
If we only had focused on the
renovation of this school,
the attendance would not
have increased by 250%.
And we also would not be
able to boast of the fact
that Ufani School now
usually goes between one
and fourth out of 150 schools.
It is number one school in
terms of school environment
in a rural area.
And also they're competing
with other schools in the city.
So you know, if we had said
let's just do the classrooms,
we wouldn't have had the
buy-in from the teachers.
We wouldn't have had the
parents who we got to now
and who started wanting their
kids to come to the school.
So what we realized is
this holistic approach
was all we could do.
And little by
little by little we
are trying to lift the
community and create
a sustainable empowering model
for the people that live there.
NELSON MATTOS: So
let me step back
and give you a little bit of a
sense of how Karimu operates.
Right?
There are three principles that
defines the model of Karimu.
The first one Marianne already
pointed to is the belief
that we as outsiders
don't really
understand as deep as
we would have to what
are the needs of the villagers.
And also, what would be the best
solution for those challenges?
And you will see actually
some examples of that.
The second is that all
projects that Karimu does
are selected together
with the village.
The village councils, midwives,
the leaders in the community,
key influencers, et cetera.
And so by doing that, you
are getting their buy-in
from the beginning.
As part of that, they also have
to be involved in the projects.
They have to get
their hands dirty.
They have to work on it.
And third is, obviously,
we focus on projects
and designing the
projects in such a way
that they are actually
self-sustained once completed.
These three principles
are implemented
in basically three different
ways, three different points.
The first one is all the
ideas, all the requests
comes from everyone.
So like the Google motto,
bottoms up, all of that
gets collected.
And then jointly with
the village councils,
the structure in the
community in Tanzania
is such that every village
has a village council.
The village council
is basically members
from the different families
that represent those families.
And there is a leader of that.
So anything that the
village council decides
gets the buy-in of
all the families.
And so, consequently, you have
the whole community behind it.
So the priorities are
decided with them.
And then Karimu
requires the community
to have three major tasks.
The first one is they
need to get the commitment
from the government.
If we're going to
build a school,
the government has to commit
to pay for the teachers
to maintain the school
afterwards, provide
school material, et cetera.
The local community has
to pay approximately 10%
of the total cost
of the construction.
This is a lot of money.
The Bancha School that
we are building this year
is going to cost $90,000.
$9,000 for the couple hundred
families that are there it
is a lot of money, a lot,
a lot, a lot of money.
To have you a sense, we
visit a school this year.
And the community decided to
build toilets for the school.
So they are collecting
$7 per family.
There are 535 families
in this village.
So $7 per family.
When I talk to the head
of the village council,
he says how many of these
families are going to pay.
He says, oh, I believe
there are about 300 families
can pay the $7 right away.
And I ask him, what
about the other 200?
He says, well, from the
other 200, there is about 100
that I'm just going
to have to go there
and nag and nag and nag.
And at some point,
they will pay the $7.
What about the remaining 100?
Says, they're going to run away.
They're going to move
out of the village
because they don't have
enough money to pay for $7.
So now you can imagine
$9,000 is really
a lot of money, which
basically means they really
need to want this.
Right?
And so you get their commitment.
You get their
involvement from day one.
And they will treat these
projects as a jewel.
Right?
They will take care.
They will make sure that
this never disappears.
They also need to
work on the project.
So they need to get
their hands dirty.
In general for constructions,
the community-- because
of the time of the year that
we start the construction,
they usually start the project.
They clean the land, and
they do all the foundations
on their own.
After that, we give
the money to hire
workers that will do the rest.
And then the volunteers
will come and do work
on some phase of the project.
And once the projects
are complete,
it's their job to
maintain and run.
You go to [INAUDIBLE]
schools, you
will see parents
cleaning the corridors
and washing the floor
of the classrooms.
You will see kids
and teachers working
in the field of the school.
So it's really-- they really
have a strong ownership.
So let me give you some
examples of these principles
with existing projects.
MARIANNE KENT-STOLL: Well, as I
said before, there were issues
and there were barriers that
I did not even know existed.
And one of them was
teachers' housing.
So once we renovated
the classrooms
and we started going from
school to school renovating
classrooms, the teachers had
us meet with them and said,
we are not going to be able to
attract teachers unless they
have adequate housing.
The government had agreed that
they would give more teachers
to these overcrowded schools.
They're really overcrowded.
For example, the
kindergartens are only
supposed to have 20
students in there.
There are 60 in each
kindergarten session.
In the fifth grade, there
are 75 students in a class
in one of the schools
that I visited.
So then we thought,
OK, well, again, we
got the village buy-in.
And this was what a
teacher was living in.
Now, if you are living in
Arusha or Dar es Salaam,
you're a
university-educated person.
Do you think you want to
come and live in a mud hut?
It would be like one of
you saying, oh, yeah,
I'll go to Switzerland.
Oh, here's a trailer
for you to live in.
And you wouldn't
want to do that.
So we honored their
professionalism
by renovating the
teachers' houses.
At Ayalagaya Secondary School,
there are three two-and-ones.
That means a family
can live here,
and a family can live there.
And again, they had to come
and help build that house.
And the other thing
that we learned about--
this is a very
interesting project.
In 2009, we did a
survey, and we discovered
that actually, the number one
killer in that village area
was respiratory disease
for adults, not malaria.
That's generally children
that have that issue.
But respiratory disease.
And the reason is that
the villagers are cooking
over open fires,
or they're often
cooking in shacks
like this where
they're breathing in the smoke.
And when we got the
results of that survey,
we asked them what's
going on here.
And they said, well,
if we had a kitchen
with fuel-efficient
stoves-- they're big,
aluminum cylinders,
and you can put
in a quarter of an
amount of the wood
that you would for an open fire.
And they're not
breathing that smoke.
And also, you can cook more
food with these fuel-efficient
cylinders so the children
can not only have lunch,
but they can also
have breakfast.
And what I didn't
realize is just
by doing this
fuel-efficient stove,
it could not only
provide more food
for the students,
less firewood, which
means they're buying
less firewood,
and that money can go towards
buying books and pencils
and repairing classrooms.
And then also, the
health of the cooks
would be greatly improved.
It broke my husband's
heart every year
when he would see Faustino
and Peter, the same cooks that
had been there for
10 years, cooking
in a black shack with their
eyes red and coughing.
The other thing that
we came to realize--
that in the village already,
there was a woman named Tumaini
who was building these small
fuel-efficient stoves--
not really because
she was thinking
about respiratory disease, but
because this is an efficient
way, if you're boiling
a pot of beans,
just to have some coals
or a little bit of wood.
And then you don't have
to start a big fire.
But she was running
this stove operation
where the profits were
going to her women's group.
But also, a small percentage
was going to the orphans.
And then she is also
training students
that may not be able to
go to secondary school,
because that's incredibly
difficult for students
sometimes who are
very poor not to be
able to get to school often,
and they have to stay home.
So she's training them to
make these stoves so that they
can have a profession.
So as you see, what was
great about this project--
it took a few years,
because it took
a while, as Nelson was saying,
to change that behavior.
Peter and Faustina, they
were in that black shack.
And I said, why aren't you
cooking in the kitchen?
And they said, well, we do
the tea in the black shack.
And I said no, no, no.
We'll get you a smaller stove.
We know you have those big ones.
We'll give you a little
one so you can do the tea.
So while we were
changing that behavior
and working on the
kitchen, we also
were supporting this more
comprehensive project, which
the two are coming together.
So not only were we learning
to see the situation in a more
broad, comprehensive
way, but Tumaini now
is helping the village
and the school students.
So I love the interconnectivity.
The other thing
about the school is
that the schools don't receive
any government funding.
Or what they do is so small,
as the head of Ayalagaya said,
it's a joke.
It's something like $5 a month
to maintain the school and all
the repairs and everything.
And so the teachers
have to find a way
to maintain the school on their
own and do their own repairs.
So what they told us is that if
we built a water irrigation--
this is not--
when people think
of Africa, they
think it's very arid and dry.
But this area actually
has a lot of water,
this particular school area.
Not all areas.
But they had too much water,
so they needed an irrigation
channel to be able
to redirect that.
That's something that Don and
I would not have thought of.
And for the cost of $1,500,
this enabled the school
to start producing crops which
then would mean that it would
provide school lunches,
which then means
they could sell the crops and
then buy their school supplies.
So for me and Don and for Nelson
and anybody else who joins us,
I feel like I'm learning
things all the time.
I think it's very
exciting to learn
how resilient these people are
and the solutions that they
come up with.
NELSON MATTOS: So as you
can see, in terms of--
it's super important to work
together with the community.
Almost nobody will
come up with the idea
of building an irrigation
system to a school.
So unless you are spending
enough time there and listening
to the locals, you
will come up with ideas
that actually don't work.
Similarly, you come
in and say, oh,
I'm going to rebuild the
school, you will never
think that unless you have
reasonable teachers' houses,
you're not going to
attract good teachers.
And if you don't
attract good teachers,
OK, you have a nice building,
but the quality of the studies
remain extremely bad.
And similarly, as
Marianne talked about,
it's super important for
you to spend enough time
and build a trust
so that you can
force them to change behavior.
All of us, actually, that
don't cook in open fire
probably think it's stupid
to be cooking in an open fire
and burn your eyes.
But many of you
have grandparents,
and probably you're
never going to convince
them to use a microwave.
Because they have
learned to cook
on a stove for their whole life.
Why would they use a microwave?
Similarly, these
people have cooked
in open fire their whole life.
They have never seen a stove.
So how do you convince them?
How do you get them to
change the way they operate?
So that takes time, and
it's a lot of hand-holding
that you have to do.
And unless you spend enough time
and build that strong trust,
you really don't
accomplish that.
So obviously, Karimu has done
many, many, many projects
there.
So let me very quickly
run through some examples.
Since 2008 to 2015,
they built and renovated
four different schools.
The enrollment has
increased by more than 250%.
So that gives you a sense
of the number of students
that were not attending
school, because their parents
felt it's not worth it.
This building is falling apart.
There is no food.
The quality of the
teacher is pretty bad.
So why should I waste my time?
This kid can help me
increase my income
through producing more crops.
Here are some of the
examples of the schools.
This is very
typical, and we have
seen two more schools
this year that
are exactly in this situation.
This is a classroom.
In addition to that, they
have built a gazillion school
toilets from something like
this to something like this.
There has been,
as Marianne said,
kitchens built in
several schools.
We have seen as a
consequence of that
the performance of the
students improve dramatically.
Obviously, these
guys come to school
without having eaten anything.
So the fact that the school
provides breakfast and lunch,
they now can pay
attention to what
is being said in the classroom.
Attendance significantly
higher, because there
is high motivation
for the parents
to send their kids to school.
And obviously, with
that, the enrollment
also has been increased
significantly.
Teachers' housing, huge impact.
On average, teachers
in that region
would spend two, maximum
three years in the school
and obviously run away.
Now the average is
going up to 10 years.
Because they have nice houses,
the environment is great,
they don't want to leave.
And obviously, the best
teachers then end up remaining.
What is most impressive
is in Tanzania,
kids in their fourth
grade and seventh grade
have to take a national exam.
If you don't pass, you cannot
progress in your study.
So if you don't pass
in the fourth grade,
you can not go to fifth grade.
If you don't pass the
7th grade, you will not
go into secondary school.
Before the houses were
built, the schools
in this area, the success rate
on this exam was below 50%.
It's now above 85%.
And the school that we
rebuilt this year, it's 95%.
This is really impressive
for a rural school.
And this is a teacher.
This is what his
house used to be.
And now he lives in this house.
So now you can imagine that
this guy is highly motivated
to stay in this area and
help improve the school.
They have done lots of
projects around education,
providing textbooks, sending
volunteers to teach at schools.
I gave some classes last year.
They have also funded for their
development for the teachers.
They pay 75% of the cost.
The teachers have to
pay 25% on their own.
And obviously, this has not
only helped the retention
of the teachers,
but also increased
the performance of the school.
Several projects around bringing
clean water into the villages
as well as into schools.
This is very typical
what you see.
This year, we visit a village--
very, very poor, dry.
There are places where the kids
and the families can get water.
The closest from the village is
two kilometers going downhill.
I saw an 8-year-old girl with
her five-year-old brother
carrying a bucket of
this size on her head.
I ask her how often
she does that,
and she very
casually said, oh, I
do it three times
in the morning,
four times during the day,
and two times in the evening.
So walking that
distance with this water
means this girl has no
way of going to school.
What is also interesting
is the moment you bring
clean water into the
school, the absence rates
gets reduced dramatically.
Because obviously, kids are
not drinking unsanitary water.
And consequently, they are not
as sick as they were before.
The clean stoves that
Marianne already talked about.
Lots of infrastructure projects.
This bridge was particularly
important in the rainy season.
This river floods.
And so instead of taking
two hours for people
to walk to school, with the
bridge, it takes 15 minutes.
The attendance rate in the rainy
season went up from 35% to 91%.
So imagine during three
months of the year,
you have the attendance at 35%.
These kids cannot catch up.
In addition to that,
there is traffic of goods
that goes through this bridge.
And if the river is flooded,
the families that have harvest
during that time of the
year, they cannot sell.
Or they have to pay somebody
to go around the river.
Help with creating a room
for people to give birth,
bring a solar panel for that,
many projects around health
in terms of trying to
reduce the mortality
rate in the region, also
education in general
about hygiene and
sanitation and diseases
that are easy to avoid,
like diarrhea, et cetera.
Also, distribution of
donations and material.
Another very important
project in the financial area
was the support for
creation of savings groups.
Savings groups are
self-organized organizations.
As you can see here, I'm meeting
with different villagers.
They meet on a regular basis.
Everybody contributes
a certain amount.
That becomes a part that people
then can use to borrow money.
And so if I need to buy
fertilizer or somebody got
sick, that will be my bank.
I can go to that, and I
will then obtain the loan.
And by doing that,
the families basically
are helping each other
address their financial needs.
This is actually quite common
in the developing world.
What is interesting--
just to see this.
The fact that they now
have access to finance,
the members of this community
that have been there
for three years triple their
income because of the access
to financial means.
The last year, that I
joined as a volunteer,
in addition to education and
training for the midwives,
we built the maternity clinic.
This is extremely important,
because mortality rate
in these parts of the
world are very high.
Infant mortality is seven
times higher than in the US,
and maternal mortality is
28 times higher than the US.
So by now, having
this maternity clinic,
39,000 people are being served.
And women can come
here to give birth.
And this is the
maternity clinic today.
We just saw it operating
with a little hospital, kids
taking vaccination.
There is doctors
and nurses there.
This year, we had 27
volunteers that went with us.
We had several projects
running in parallel.
A teacher from California
organized classes
in all schools
for arts, science,
and interactive learning
with different subjects.
A family from California that
owns a solar panel company
came and actually installed
solar panels in all schools
and in the maternity clinic.
So the maternity clinic
now is fully equipped,
can run the equipments that
are necessary, et cetera.
My brother, who
is a sports freak,
organized a sports
competition with 120 kids.
This was a huge success.
We taught IT to all
of the teachers,
taught them Google Docs,
registered everybody in Gmail,
also on Facebook.
So now we can continue
remotely bringing
new information and new
educational material for them.
And we set up a learning
center in the secondary school
that all the teachers will
be able to access the news.
The biggest project
was the reconstruction
of the Bacho Primary School.
This is how the
school looked before.
This is a classroom
with no electricity.
How can you actually
even see what the teacher
is writing on the blackboard?
And this is the
third of the school.
The school is being built in--
there are three buildings.
The first one has
just completed.
We as volunteers finished this.
We have just to do the painting.
And these are three classrooms
and the teacher's office.
And in the rest, we worked
on the second building.
We set the foundations
as well as the walls.
So in summary, as
I had mentioned,
the traditional development
is having a lot of challenges.
Because the way they used to
operate with middlemen NGOs
that allow them to
spend enough time
and create comprehensive
solutions are dying out.
And consequently,
you are not being
able to have the impact that you
used to have with nonprofits.
Karimu avoids that
by, as I said,
believing that the
villagers really
understand their problems
and working with them,
forcing them to not only
define the projects,
but having a skin in the
game and contributing
to the projects,
working on them,
maintaining them, getting
the government support,
and ensuring that the
projects are self-sustainable.
Moving forward, now that I
joined forces with Marianne,
we are going to
really be expanding.
Those of you that
know me, I tend
to do multiple
things in parallel.
So we're going to be running
multiple large projects
at the same time.
We have just hired
another person
that is going to
be on the ground
so that we can execute these
projects throughout the year.
We are going to be also
expanding beyond the district
that we are currently operating.
When we were there, we met
with the head of the region.
It's like the state in Tanzania.
They are super committed
in support to us.
They were super impressed
with the projects.
And they are going to help.
The government is going
to help us give us
the priority of what
should be the next two
districts for us to operate.
And we are, in parallel,
building a three
to five-year strategic plan.
After we do a complete
assessment of the area,
identifying what are all the
places needing water, what
are all the schools that
need bathrooms, what
need teacher's housing,
et cetera, so that we
can comprehensively
start addressing all these
problems at the same time.
And I already mentioned the
support from the government.
Let me skip the
projects for next year.
And in addition to
finishing the school,
we are going to be
focusing heavily
on bringing clean water to two
villages that have no water.
I told you the story
about the girl,
and also the schools
on these villages
trying to rebuild them.
There is many opportunities
for you guys to get involved.
I hope I have touched the
hearts of some of you.
If you would like
to experience what
it is to do some really hands-on
volunteer work, join us.
We go to Africa, to Tanzania
every year between mid June
to early July.
And you're going to work side
by side with the villagers.
It's going to be a wonderful
cultural experience.
If you feel insecure,
don't worry about it.
We use an organization
I had mentioned before,
Inspire Worldwide.
They are specialized in
organizing volunteer tours
for Africa and Asia.
They handle your
safety, transportation,
all the logistics, where we
stay, et cetera, et cetera.
If you have any questions,
you can ping me,
or you can send an email
directly to Karimu Foundation.
Obviously, if you don't feel
like joining as a volunteer,
help us.
You can donate by going to
www.karimufoundation.org.
And one thing I would
like to emphasize
is that every single
penny you will donate
is going to go to the projects.
Dawn, Marianne, as
well as the folks
that she has on the ground
work for free, like me.
We don't get a single penny.
The volunteers that
also go once a year,
they pay all their expenses.
So every dollar you
donate are going
to be used for the projects.
I want to use this opportunity
to thank many, many Googlers
that actually have contributed
to the reconstruction
of [INAUDIBLE] School.
I was really touched by the
fact that we had 181 Googlers
and ex-Googlers that
came forward and actually
helped us collect enough
money to really reconstruct
the school.
And I hope people will
continue to help us,
because there is a
lot more to be done.
Thank you very, very much.
MARIANNE KENT-STOLL:
And I'd like
to say thank you to all of you.
You've been a
wonderful audience.
And I want to thank Nelson.
As many of you know,
he's a powerhouse.
And I really admire that in him.
But what I admire most of all
is that Don and I welcomed him
to this project.
We are pretty picky,
because we want
people that have
cultural sensitivity
and that are really
compassionate.
Being smart is
fantastic, but you've
got to have the heart
as well as the brain.
And you also have
to have patience
and be willing to listen.
And he's all of those things.
So thank you very much.
And thank you.
This is wonderful being here.
Thank you very much.
RAFAEL: Thank you so much
for the inspiring talk.
Thank you.
MARIANNE KENT-STOLL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RAFAEL: So maybe have time
for one or two questions.
And since I know
Nelson personally,
I actually want to ask you a
personal question if I may.
You look back to a very
successful tech career.
You retired from Google.
You could be sitting on a
sailing boat in the Caribbean
and enjoy retirement.
Maybe you do this.
NELSON MATTOS: I do that, too.
RAFAEL: Exactly.
I saw you on a couple
of those pictures
with really dirty hands,
like literally dirty hands.
How does that feel, and what
does it give you personally?
NELSON MATTOS: It's
extremely difficult
to describe what
you feel when you
are doing volunteer work,
particularly hands-on volunteer
work in this area.
All I can tell you is
it's extremely gratifying.
It's extremely satisfying.
The eyes of the
people there, the way
they thank you, the way they
show gratitude for what you do,
is so fulfilling.
It's impossible to walk away.
I came to Tanzania this
year for the second time.
So there was a lot of
people that I have met.
And it was an
incredible feeling.
The moment I was
arriving in the village,
I was feeling like
I'm back home.
And people were coming to
me, and how's your son,
and how's your wife,
and what about this,
and what about that.
We are fortunate.
We in the developed
countries have grown in a way
that we have distanced
ourselves from our communities.
And they are extremely tight.
And the moment you
arrive there, you
are part of their community.
You are part of their family.
We tend to focus on us
first, second the family,
third the community.
They are exactly the
opposite-- community first,
my family second, me
as a person third.
And it's incredible to see
somebody making a decision that
is not the best for
them personally,
but it's the right thing
to do for the community.
We would never do that.
When we arrived this year-- and
last year was the same thing--
you get to the institute where
we actually stay overnight.
About 300 meters
from the institute,
there were probably 1,000
people waiting for you.
And you get out of this bus.
Everybody is dancing.
Everybody is singing,
welcoming you.
And you are walking
along this path.
There is the traditional
dancers dancing
their traditional things.
You walk a little bit.
There is the choir
from the church,
and then the choir
from the school,
and then the midwives all
thanking you and welcoming you
back home.
So you really feel like you
are the sun that is coming back
home for five to six years.
It's impossible.
I don't want to talk some more
because I will start crying.
RAFAEL: Exactly.
I think it's very telling.
That's exactly why I asked.
It sounds like it's
very rewarding for you.
And that's very impressive, and
I think touches a lot of us.
Thank you so much, Nelson.
Maybe the final question
to you, Marianne.
So from listening
to all of this,
it sounds like you
established maybe a best
practice in how to do this.
That's how I understood
what you're saying here.
I wonder, in terms
of vision and future,
do you personally think
you want to stay at that,
and you maybe want to grow
Karimu as it is today,
or would you even
see potentially maybe
to roll out those best
practices for other NGOs
and maybe grow, in
a sense, the method?
MARIANNE KENT-STOLL: I think
that's an excellent question.
There's a company
called Quantify
in Santa Cruz that has been
giving us a $20,000 matching
grant every year.
And they have
endorsed this model.
But the owner, Ken
Terry, always says
you should mentor other
people, because you
could have replicated
models in other villages.
And it does take
time, because you
have to stay in this
same community--
not creating dependency because
you don't stay in one school,
but you move from
school to school,
from medical center to
other medical center.
But you have to stay
in that community.
So I would like to
expand, but like this.
And also, I would like to be
able to mentor other people.
And this summer, we had the
opportunity to mentor David
Newman and his wife,
Laura, who came and stayed
some time in the village.
Because they just started an
NGO, and they want to know how
we do it.
And they watched us
for about five days.
And it was very, very
gratifying to have
them ask us questions, to walk
with us through the village.
So I'd like to continue
replicating that model,
with the idea with small
things, with concentrated work,
you can do really,
really great things.
NELSON MATTOS: Let me add
to what Marianne said.
I think Karimu has two goals.
In addition to increase
the impact in this region
and slowly expand graphically,
the second big role--
and I think this is probably
what will be the most
powerful--
is to create a new model
for social development.
Given that the existing
model is falling apart,
become a showcase of how you can
be doing successful development
work and hopefully have
many, many other NGOs falling
exactly the same principle.
RAFAEL: Wonderful.
Thanks again so much for
sharing this with us,
and the trust, and
everything you do.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]